the mother of a missing Colorado woman
is revealing new information about the
day her daughter vanished no one has
reported seeing Kelsey Bharath since her
fiance picked up their one-year-old
daughter three weeks ago
police considered a missing persons case
and haven't named any suspects Niki
batiste spoke with Barrett's mother
about their last conversation and she's
in Woodland Park that's just outside
Colorado Springs Nicki good morning good
morning
Cheryl Barrett's believes Kelsey is
still alive and somewhere here in
Colorado she told us the last time she
spoke with her daughter she seemed
normal and happy and that she's not the
type of person to just run off and leave
behind her baby girl I think she wants
to be found she has no reason to be
hiding she's got a desperately miss
Kaylee Sheryl Bharath spoke with Kelsey
on the phone Thanksgiving morning
shortly before the 29 year old went
shopping with her daughter Caylee at a
Woodland Park Colorado supermarket what
did she say she needed a recipe she had
something she wanted to make that
afternoon did she say what her
Thanksgiving plans were there was the
possibility of going out to dinner after
her fiance Patrick Frazee who was also
Kaylee's father picked up the
one-year-old Bharath vanished three days
later on November 25th cell towers
outside Gooding Idaho nearly 600 miles
away picked up a signal from Barriss
phone her parents live in the northern
part of the state did Kelsey have any
plans does she's mentioned to you at all
that she might be heading died oh no was
she going hiking that day or anything no
she won't go anywhere by herself like
that is there any chance she would have
just planned a week away is there any
chance she was just stressed out I
seriously doubt it Frazee says he also
got a text message from Bharath on
november 25th but nothing since he never
reported her missing I couldn't believe
that no one had heard from her I
contacted police that makes no sense
that we can't find her is she excited to
get married yes I mean it's yeah yeah
they had they have plans no date but but
plans she have a dress yet no no I don't
think she cared about the big wedding
kind of thing
yeah it was between them and God
police say Frazee is not a suspect and
is cooperating with the investigation in
a statement his lawyer said Frazee has
given interviews to law enforcement
turned over his phone and provided cheek
swabs and photographs I'm hopeful that
she'll be found completely 100% safely I
know somebody knows where she's at and
who is hoping for Kelsey's safe return
as Carrie Frazee's lawyer says his
client who is hoping for Kelsey's safe
return is caring for their daughter
Kaylee Idaho State Police tell CBS News
this morning they did look into those
cell phone tower pings but so far they
have no active leads biana alright Nicki
let's hope for a happy ending especially
with the holidays just a few weeks away
thank you